hey everybody and welcome to the Shan
method on today we're today's episode
yeah also on today but specifically on
today's episode we're going all the way
back to 2006 with hitman blood money I'm
before time a time before the age of man
so hitman blood money has what is widely
regarded as one of the best levels in
the series which is called a new life
and you're out to kill this former crime
lord i was living in suburban Southern
California he's under the protection of
the witness protection program sounds
that's the FBI and all that basically
I'm we sneak into his house and try to
kill the guy here we go not dressed like
someone who belongs in the burbs no no
step one is always always try to get
inside people's head when you can you
got to show them what's do I mean oh I
didn't like to kill that guy should I
hide his dead body maybe in this hole
yeah maybe you should put it in a hole
down you go whoa whoa wait didn't even
make it down oh yeah he's down there
don't worry about him I'm gonna get into
this guy's head yeah you like that Hey
oh he's PO okay okay yeah I'm the coin
killer that's my calling card is I leave
30 coins on the ground anytime I do it
or this is what our doors open should i
feel like i can just roam inside just
when I think that child is very small
it's all I kill kind of paint oh wow
these guys he just try to run you off
yeah right like I'm gonna get out of
here you guys are jerks know who you are
going to do the to plot to kill oh yeah
Vinny sinistro oh I'm dead I died and
you tell me you're dead you're still
cutting my singing is going really slow
and I can kill one more guy I have time
for nope I'm dead all right okay we're
good problem solved problem solved step
10 get changed step 2 you drag this out
what again change the color of your tie
and that is literally it okay it's not
going to
I'm going so hot i love how they get
into their first question mode whoa whoa
serpentine motion I'm never gonna aw
take so long to reload two guns what
tonight oh oh you're a broker drawers
older you'll join whenever oh my live
again what was that the last standard no
I'm dead no no no okay slowly die that
was our second dry run we got it out of
her system he's like well they said
fitness was gonna be its own reward but
here's this guy giving me money he has
got a real big coin purse on him this is
an FBI survey what's up feds here I got
you doughnuts hey yeah right your
loyalties ground doughnuts yeah cool is
that full disclosure get these down now
look at these jerks eating these donut
what they're going down for the count oh
there's Xbox snap jerks eating doughnuts
oh no oh no these donut just it was
really weird about this bonus oh so now
they're having a nice little nap time
mm-hmm but you can never lead to say
little did they know they are never
gonna wake up what's this guy looking at
you're not on to my disguise are you are
you know you're good then team to enjoy
a peaceful moment he's been working and
catering for 50 years yeah yeah yeah you
like that a little tip for the caterer I
like those hot dogs that you brought
excuse me I am an FBI man you can tell
that by the black tie and the sunglasses
look damned wires coming into our
livestream 35 seconds until the lobby
slark get it up here well Shh danny has
brought a giant yoga ball here which
I'll now mom is sitting here get into
the frame see you meanwhile on the Sean
method where nothing weird ever happens
we're doing pretty good no one suspects
the clown until the clown picks a lock
oh wow Oh witness is you just put a mine
in front
ah I won't be bothering us anytime soon
oh hello oh no no you always die when
it's in the slow motion mode yeah it
takes forever for you to die so you can
still like kill people and then you can
die upon them in demonizing ways yeah
I'll flip through each oh no clip
through the couch the most inefficient
dragger of bodies what is what turn
around and grab both legs and scoop back
no no don't you run by gorgeous yeah
real great danger gorgeous teen bear
days here I can walk at a brisk pace as
fast as you are doing yeah you're real
[ __ ] jogger I want you to know that
buddy is pretty fit I mean oh he's
already out of breath is why don't you
just like get to know the neighbors
first use me hello ma'am I want you to
know that I posed no threat to you do
you need some help Oh with your face
I'll take this put her out of her misery
is too loud screaming oh no oh God Oh
what right in the traps we're good don't
even sweat now you're gonna do your
stupid what body hall not so hard I
guess want to get to this situation
these guys are really protective of the
no man there's so many guys [ __ ] eat
it jerks you oh wow it worked why did
you let me kill that lady with the hedge
cutter god damn it Chris look I want you
to eat at her up you always do it it is
born yes man to gain access to this
house and not at all suspicious here let
me tip you you've been quite kind
essentially murdering her essentially
she's gonna float though I think anybody
see me no perfect crime oh I feel like I
should push this guy no pool you really
gotta get in there don't you get in get
in the pool don't you have a shove move
I do but then he's gonna that's gonna
piss off the FBI guards come on get in
the pool you jerk I need you to get in
this pool are you are you sniffing his
farts I'm really confused about your
tactics here Wow now I'm not confused
anymore it's become very clear haha
alright fine fine I
see how it is money's on the dresser oh
wait what's happening in the small pool
oh they found a bag tura oh she's not
dead guys she's not dead she's not dead
I gave her a set of you doing this
stupid boat why don't any of these guys
ask for help dragging bodies it wasn't
me guys I found the killer he's in here
but it wasn't me uh-oh where D oh whoa I
dude has some cavities oh there's
another door to the kitchen there was he
a vampire Oh where's that clown is
running willy-nilly all over the place
oh I found has rainbow socks that's
tight what you think that you're immune
to this whole situation clown you think
you're gonna get out of this one alive
clown and now I disguise myself and
we're just fine no witnesses murder
clown time to get stabbed by a clown
it's everyone's worst nightmare excuse
me my friend have you seen where a
murder is happening around here no I not
pay attention to what I have hiding
behind my back it's okay come on all the
wine bottles with all you booze hounds
knock back oh no I can't I can't kill
him like this this is he's surrendering
he's a city worker all that was horrible
turns out I actually can't kill yep
that's you know why hey bud I'm wearing
pants I and the clown from your worst
nightmares are you gonna just die in an
inferno no oh [ __ ] did you just manage
to murder yourself and not him nope oh
you definitely murdered him oh no no get
up shoot him in the wrist yeah we're
good oh I died she's gonna fit on you
with the fit oh no why would you tell
the FBI guys wait just let her go don't
try to snip her but now what did the
xbox is just freeze the Xbox freeze on
us I don't want to just kill ladies Oh
every time we're good don't sweat it oh
look look look jogger it's a dead lady
don't you want to see what happened oh
you shot him in his jogging but where
are you going yard boss man
huh now you're just being a garbage man
I'm a garbage man just get home in there
would you like to welcome me in are you
just gonna stand there are you fellow
investigators or let's investigate each
other's faces here why you bend over and
pick that up for me whoa okay wow you're
right get out of there every meter is
freaking out it started washing does it
start doing that when it's like a real
sexy situation I think yeah when he's
like kind of got half a chub going on I
think it starts uh hello ma'am oh please
don't pay any attention to me sneaking
around like that oh I'm not sneaking I'm
just a regular guy wow she chided you
and now your meter is not flashing oh
gosh no no don't look in here it's fine
oh you're just doing the swimming
exercise well turns out she's good at
swimming she's got it so I'm gonna vote
on your back for a number of minutes
it's a bad situation you have to
literally bleep oh we're good oh no it's
okay you ever gonna die it's okay all
right you got a head now we run oh [ __ ]
serpentine motion how do you escape yep
Gator was a witness I got a I got a
gunshot you my head you need to throw
some mines that oh god oh oh oh he's
made it a while all right everybody
thank you very much for watching if you
guys have any suggestions for future
episodes let me know in the comments let
me know in on Twitter the tweets don't
let me know on Twitter chat because
that's going to disappear in like 30
seconds that is very ephemeral but on
Twitter hit me up at s McInnes and let
me know any games that you want to see
on future episodes